نقلت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال الامريكيه عن
مصادر تاكيدها ان الشرق الاوسط يستعد
لضربات امريكيه على الحوثيين مشيره الى ان
دبلوماسيين غربيين اورد ان الاهداف
المحتمله هي مواقع اطلاق صواريخ ومسيرات
للحوثيين واضافت الصحيفه الامريكيه ان
الدبلوماسيين الغربيين ابلغوا مسؤولين في
مجال الشحن البحري ان الاهداف ستكون حول
محافظتي الحديده
وحجه ينضم الينا من امام مقار الحكومه
البريطانيه في لندن مراس الجزيره اسد الله
الصاوي كما ينضم الينا من البنتاغون مراس
الجزيره فادي منصور فادي لطالما قالت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انها لا تريد
محاربه الحوثيين انما تامين الملاحه في
البحر الاحمر من خلال ما ذكره البنتاجون
اليوم ما هو المستشف حول طبيعه ما يجري في
ظل التصريحات لعدد من الصحف
الامريكيه يمكننا ان نقول ان منسوب التوتر
ما بين الولايات المتحده وانصار الله
الحوثيين بلغ مستوى كبير للغايه وربما غير
مسبوق ما يفتح الاحتمالات واسعه امام عمل
عسكري ما من قبل الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في البحر الاحمر تجاه المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في اليمن
الولايات المتحده كانت حذرت في بيان
الاسبوع الماضي مع عدد من الدول الحليفه
وشريكه لها انصار الله الحوثيين من ان
استمرارهم في شن الهجمات على السفن
التجاريه في جنوب البحر الاحمر سوف يترتب
عليه تبعات اليوم مره اخرى المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون الجنرال بات رايدر اشار الى هذا
الامر وكان وضعه في سياق مختلف يوم
الثلاثاء عندما اعتبر ان ذلك البيان يمثل
تحذيرا وبان على الحوثيين ان ياخذوه على
محمل الجد وان لا يستهين بهذه التحذيرات
الولايات المتحده قالت انها لا تسعى لنزاع
مع الحوثيين وبان الاطار
التحالفين حو 20 دوله لحمايه الملاحه
التجاريه البحريه في البحر الاحمر تحت
مسمى حارس الازدهار هذا التحالف غير معني
باتخاذ اجراءات هجوميه ضد انصار الله
الحوثيين في اليمن وهو معني فقط بمساله
الردع وحمايه السفن لكن الهجمات
المتزايده لا سما الهجوم الذي وقع من قبل
يومين ووصفته الولايات المتحده بانه معقد
واستخدم خلاله انصار الله الحوثيين مسيرات
وصاروخ بالستي واحد على الاقل مضاد للسفن
وعدد من الصواريخ الكروز المضاده للسفن
مضطر ثلاثه سفن حربيه امريكيه ورابعه
بريطانيه تصدي لها كان رفع منسوب التوتر
الى مستوى جديد وينظر اليه على انه كان رد
عملي من التحذيرات للتحذيرات الامريكيه
الموجهه لانصار الله الحوثيين وبالتالي
هناك توتر والقول ان الولايات المتحده ده
لن ترد هذا عمليا لا ياتي في سياق عمليه
حارس الازدهار البنتاجون شدد وكما اوضح
المتحدث باسمه الجنرال رايدر بان الولايات
المتحده تستطيع كما قال قائد القوات
البحريه الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ادميرال كوبر من خارج هذا التحالف ان تقوم
بعمل عسكري لكنه رفض ان يتكهن طبيعه هذا
العمل علما ان الولايات المتحده حتى
اللحظه تقول انلا دلائل ومعطيات مؤكده بان
الضربات التي وجهها انصار الله الحوثيين
والهجمات التي شنوها والتي بلغت حتى اليوم
مع الهجوم الذي وقع اليوم بصاروخ بالستي
مضاد للسفن بلغت 27 هجوما ان ايا من هذه
الهجمات ليس هناك معطيات واضحه اذا كان اي
منها يستهدف القوات الامريكيه والسفن
الامريكيه التي ت اتخذت اجراءات دفاعيه
وبالتالي الساعات المقبله قد تحمل تطور
غير مسبوقه في سياق تعامل عسكري قد يكون
من قبل الولايات المتحده واطراف حليفه لها
اخرى في المنطقه ابقى معنا فادي اسد يعني
على الجانب البريطاني هنالك تحركات
وتسريبات لبعض الصحف ايضا تتحدث عن
امكانيه توجيه ضاره للحوثيين هذا ما ذكرته
التايمز البريطانيه كيف هي هذه
التحركات
رسميا فداء رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه عقد
اجتماعا طارئا لحكومته عبر الهاتف هذا
الاجتماع شهد وزير الخارجيه وهو يدخل الى
مقر الحكومه ديفيد كاميرون لكي يحضر هذا
الاجتماع وحسب التسريبات الوارده في وسائل
الاعلام هذا الاجتماع لاطلاع المسؤولين في
حكومه ريشي سوناك على اجراءات عسكريه ضربه
محتمله ستتخذها كل من الولايات المتحده و
بانيا ضد ضد اهداف تابعه لجماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين في اليمن تم استدعاء ايضا
رئيس البرلمان وتم استدعاء كذلك زعيم
المعارضه ووزير الدفاع في حكومه الظل
المعارضه كل هذه الاجراءات عاده فد يعني
يتم اتخاذها قبل اتجا اتخاذ اجراء عسكري
معين يتعلق بالامن القومي البريطاني في
الصوره ايضا اجتماع للجنه الطوارئ الحكومي
كوبرا عقد في هذا الصباح وفي الصوره ايضا
اجتماع
لمجلس الامني او مجلس الامن القومي
البريطاني عقد قبل عده ساعات وبالتالي من
الواضح ان هناك تحضيرات يتم اتخاذها من
قبل الحكومه لتمهيد الطريق من اجل تنفيذ
هجمات محدده في هذه المنطقه لابد من
التذكير فدا بان وزي الخارجيه والدفاع
البريطانيين كرر اكثر من مره خلال اليومين
الماضيين ان جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ستواجه يعني عواقب ان لم تتوقف عن شن
هجمات على السفن في البحر الاحمر بالنسبه
للمسؤولين البريطانيين هذه الهجمات لا
تشمل فقط كما تقول جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين السفن التجاريه المرتبطه
باسرائيل وانما حسب المسؤولين البريطانيين
تشمل جميع السفن التي تمر في هذه المنطقه
الحيويه من العالم مضيق باب المندب يجب
الاشاره ايضا الى البيان الذي صدر قبل نحو
اسبوع من قبل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وعده دول اخرى وجه هذا البيان تحذيرا
صارما لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين بان
عليها ان تتوقف بريطانيا تشارك في تحالف
حارس الازدهار في البحر الاحمر ب مدمره
احدى احدث مدمرات ه اتش ام اس داياموند
ولها ايضا اتش ام اس لانكاستر سفينه
عسكريه بريطانيه اكبر موجوده في بحر العرب
توقع ان تشاركا في مثل هذه الضربات ان تمت
بالفعل